hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 11 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet there's a whole bunch of
comic book stuff we have to talk about
there's a new round of the giveaway now
- all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so because there's so much comic
book stuff I'm gonna do my top 10 WTF
and I'll just explain the comic book
Easter eggs and all the references as I
go along so right off the bat number 10
Carl's forced to see his father naked
after he gets the drop on Jesus what the
hell are you doing in my house I'm just
I'm just waiting for your mom and dad
that was so great your mom and dad
he says what everyone's been thinking
for the past week I mean if a lot of you
were Rishon shippers you probably
thought of Michonne as the mom in that
equation anyway so there's nothing new
for you but really last week wasn't the
first time for me where I was like yeah
definitely Carl's mom now and it sounds
like Jesus blesses their union all the
better feel kind of bad for Carl having
to see his parents naked so quickly but
he can tell the therapist about it while
everyone's gone number nine WCF Abraham
is straight-up pancake trippin all
episode long so he has this moment with
Sasha if you remember there was kind of
a moment between them and it gets super
awkward where he's trying to flirt with
her but he's still Rosita he's having
trouble moving forward this whole
episode was about people making new
lives for themselves Abraham not being
sure about it let me ask you a question
when you're pouring the Bisquick were
you trying to make a pancake that was
one of my favorite sayings from the
episode Abraham always has the best
sangs mother dick pancakes Bisquick my
read on him by the end of the episode
though is that he sees that sonogram and
it seems like a hopeful look in his face
so he's like okay yeah I'm ready to move
forward I'm ready to start making
pancakes I think the real question to
ask though is is he gonna be making
pancakes with Rosita or will he start
making pancakes with Sasha number seven
WTF Jesus blows everyone's minds and
explains what he does I find new trade
routes for my community wait a sec you
have other trade routes there are other
communities out there your world is
about to get a whole lot bigger
one of the biggest themes of the Walking
Dead is that everywhere they go is like
the last place on earth the world is a
big place but the world of the
apocalypse is relatively self-contained
so anywhere we don't go we really don't
talk about the survivors don't talk
about a lot of other big places but of
course there's
tons of other pockets of humanity trying
to survive the people at Hilltop even
the saviors didn't sound like they have
that many people but it was such a great
intro and it's almost like the show is
telling us there is a much larger world
that you don't know about yet even
though we're in season 6 we've done a
lot of things there's still so much more
story to tell
number 6 WTF the survivors save Jesus's
friends who went to get medicine I love
how they just plastered walkers all over
that car it looked like someone just
tried to run over a giant group of
walkers and that's what flipped them
over you just hit the jackpot I used to
be an obstetrician I have a ton of
medicine in my back here in a sonogram
machine anytime you hear stuff like that
like oh my god this is so perfect you
just you wait for someone to yank the
rug out from under you if walking dead
has taught you anything it is to be
completely mistrustful of really good
things like even with Rick grabbing
Michonne's hand and squeezing it you
know that really tender moment just
feels kind of ominous like yeah we may
have been again bum please according to
Abraham I love the way he said that but
they're only allowed to have that much
fun because something really terrible is
coming next in the saviour's in negan
number five WTF banjo intro to hilltop
there was this weird I don't know if it
was banjo music but it was this Twiggy
plucky old-timey version of The Walking
Dead theme as they walked into hilltop
it was like they were walking into a
historical reenactment just with
everybody in post-apocalyptic clothing
and that's the way Jesus explains it the
Barrington house it's really part of
this community that was meant to be
self-sustaining before technology became
a big thing so it's perfect for their
needs right now and it's our first
really big comic book moment the first
time hilltop appeared in the comics was
issue number 94 in the way things played
out in this episode was pretty
comic-book accurate with Ethan coming in
trying to stab Gregory then teasing the
Savior's Gregory being a complete
douchebag speaking of which number four
WTF Gregory is like a rapey creep Oh
tune down version of the governor
someone who still tries to be an
administrator but is a terrible person
now if you have rid of the comics and
you want to talk about what ends up
happening to his character please use
spoiler tags because we just met some of
these characters they're pretty big in
the comics so the odds are we're gonna
be waiting into like super duper spoiler
territory especially with all the negan
stuff just because you get such a huge
character
but the brief introduction that we did
get to Gregory was pretty accurate like
the way the actor portrayed the
character was pretty accurate to the
comic book character he's a douchebag
that gives off a Creepo vibe to all the
women everyone shuts him down in the way
Maggie shut him down in this episode
number three WTF Ethan comes charging in
on the orders of negan to kill Gregory
like I said right out of the comic books
riggan the survivors have this awesome
take down in written everyone just
starts freaking out I love how Rick
turned around and was just like what
what are you looking at what's the big
deal so we learned number two WTF things
are not as simple as they seem Jesus
explains the deal that they have with
negan and the Savior's one half of
everything we have in exchange for
protection protection from whom he might
ask from the Savior's so it's like negan
offers protection from his own fists or
baseball bat as the case may be now he
does have the baseball bat called
Lucille and I love that line from Jesus
where he said that negan wanted to set
things up between them told them how
that was going to be right off the bat
the metaphor is slowly becoming a
reality and it is going to be so amazing
once it shows up don't know exactly
which episode negan's gonna show up in
but number one WCF the deal is made the
survivors are gonna take down negan get
Ethan's brother Craig back in exchange
for food so that's why we see Rick and
the teaser for the next episode trying
to sell the rest of the SafeZone
survivors on going after negan we need
to do this because we need the food that
hilltop can offer so I have no idea
which episode exactly we're gonna
finally get to Savior's but it's
probably gonna come pretty soon we've
only got five episodes left in the
season so I'm hoping that we see negan
in the last two episodes so that we get
like two hours of negan before season
seven but let me know in the comments
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and what was the funniest moment
you thought from the episode like I love
all the negan puns boogie man baseball
bat man boogie man ain't nothin Daryl
just absolutely does not care it's gonna
be so awesome when they finally see him
and Abraham was hilarious Bisquick
pancakes huggin bum plays he was on fire
but he still hasn't taught mother dick
mother dick is still my favorite Abraham
saying why you guys think about that
I'll say congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Ben aroni please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact details it's just
a $20 Amazon gift card
the Oscars is tonight but there was a
little bit of Batman V Superman footage
that dropped so I'll be doing a video
for that next I know a lot of you are
worried about them toning negan down
from the comics he's an amazing
character but he's so graphic that
there's just things that they can't do
on TV they're not allowed to do Robert
Kirkman said that they're filming
everything in that stuff that does not
make it to air will make it to the DVD
so you will get pure comic-book negan
issues of the most hardcore parts of
that will only make it onto the DVD
release I am so excited about Jeffrey
Dean Morgan I cannot wait to see him why
you guys wait for my next video you can
click here to learn all about the big
WTF twist George R Martin was teasing
for Game of Thrones and you can click
here for all my Walking Dead videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's have five I'll see you guys
tonight